hi guys and welcome back to my channel
today i want to talk to you a little bit
about the state of affairs of my
language learning journey
and how i managed to learn three
languages actively while maintaining a
few others
my name is luca lampariello i'm a
language coach who speaks 14 languages
and on this channel i help people learn
languages faster
better and with more fun so what are the
languages that i
am actively learning in the last year
i've basically been learning
three languages actively hungarian greek
and
danish and today i wanted to talk a
little bit about
my initial plans for 2020 the things
that i did right
and wrong over the course of the year
and the big lessons i've learned from
learning each
of these three languages both separately
and together as a group
first let's talk about weak greek is a
language that i have
literally fallen in love with personally
i like saying that greek has an italian
heart
and a spanish voice and they say this
because greek sounds a lot like spanish
but greek people
act a lot like italians in fact these
are just two of the many many reasons
why this language
really resonates with me ella mamu
at the beginning of 2020 i told myself
that i wanted to learn greek
every single day to pursue my goal of
truly mastering this beautiful language
and though i haven't mastered greek
quite yet i certainly succeeded in my
daily
learning goals in 2020 i managed to
spend time with greek almost
every single day and even now i truly
enjoy
every single moment of it over the
course of the year i made sure that
every morning
after completing my morning routine the
first thing i did was
watch one youtube video in greek
normally the video was taken from
among my favorite channels like easy
greek which features
street interviews with greek people and
by the way dimitris and marilena if you
ever watch this video i love you guys
anestronio
which is a very cool channel that offers
visually
stunning videos and super duper
interesting content about astronomy
no matter which video i watched i made
sure that it was about a topic that i
personally found
compelling and motivating to watch
luckily i found
three or four greek channels that are
full of content that i truly enjoy
so i was and still am to this day
able to rotate between them i posted
some links in the description box for
those who are learning greek or are
simply native greek speakers interested
in these topics
as i engaged in this habit over the
course of the year i started to notice
something interesting
while at the beginning of the year i had
to rely mostly on the subtitles in greek
to understand what was being said
as time went on i was able to understand
more and more of the authentic content
without outside help and considering
that for the most part
these are channels that are intended
mainly for native greek speakers
and not learners like me that was
extremely motivating so
what else did i do to learn greek during
the year
well in addition to my youtube listening
practice
i also started listening to podcasts
and on top of that i met once a week
with dadia an
excellent fantastic re-tutor whom i
found on italki
the conversations with dadia are
important because they help me develop
my language skills
in a way that suits my interests before
a weekly meeting i make sure to choose
the topic of conversation
and prepare a few different phrases and
words that i want to try out
then during the session i record
everything so that
afterwards i can spend as much time as i
need practicing the things that i
learned from dada during the
conversation
all of these things that i did to learn
greek during the year taught me the true
value of being consistent since i was
able to learn greek at least a little
bit every day
all of those daily improvements
compounded to create a result that was
better than i
even expected at the end of last year i
was completely surprised to look back on
my first greek journal entry for 2020
and find that back
then i was still listening to simple
podcasts that by now i find
completely trivial it turns out that i
made a lot of progress over the last
calendar year and that
quite frankly is an incredible feeling
for example i'm able to read long and
interesting articles on wikipedia
i can watch nearly any video in greek
when with
and without subtitles and understand the
gist of it i'm able to understand
podcasts aimed
at native speakers i can speak much more
freely
and with much less effort than before
and so much more
what should you take away from this well
if you can commit to consistently
learning a language
every single day or almost every single
day for a long period of time
then the results will follow this is a
so-called compound effect in action and
if it worked for me with greek
it can and will work for you as well i
promise
learning greek in 2020 also taught me
the value of focusing on systems
rather than goals most language goals
deal with reaching a specific skill
target at a specific time
however this year i focused instead on
mastering
my day they say that a day is a life in
miniature
so to improve my greek i focused mainly
on building the daily habits that would
make success
inevitable in the long run with my
youtube podcast
and language tutoring habits that i
developed for greek during the year
i truly believe i have succeeded in
doing just that
okay now let's talk about hungarian
hungarian is another language that i
really
really love learning it's quite exotic
compared to the other european languages
i know
so it's really fascinating to dive into
i've been learning hungarian since late
2016. so for about five years now
and because of that i have to confess
that in 2020 hungarian often took a
backseat to greek which was newer
and more exciting for me when you've
built a strong well-developed core
in a language putting a language aside
in this way is usually not too harmful
for example i can go months or even
years without speaking some of my
strongest languages simply because
i know them so well that is above a b1
b2 level at least
that they do not easily deteriorate the
thing is though that i do not know
hungarian that well
just yet although i've been learning it
for years i haven't given it the time
and attention necessary to make that
push
and get it above a b2 that's not to say
that i've been completely ignoring the
language though in fact i still spend
about 30 minutes a week speaking to each
of my two hungarian tutors
petra and anita and while that combined
one hour a week of speaking practice may
sound like a lot for some of you it
really is not enough
if you want to improve your skills in a
serious way
the truth is if i want to get better at
hungarian i need
to practice speaking it more this leads
me to my second issue with hungarian
2020 which was similar
but not quite the same this leads me to
my second issue with hungarian 2020
getting enough interesting
comprehensible input earlier
i spoke about how i had found a group of
three
or four greek channels full of
fascinating video content that i love to
listen to
well i have to admit that i haven't
found such channels for hungarian just
yet
perhaps worse i know of a few that could
suit my interest and learning needs
but they do not come with hungarian
subtitles for me to use
my hungarian skills are still to the
point where target language subtitles
are extremely helpful so
the complete lack of good subtitles on
the hungarian channels i've found
has been really demotivating so
what lesson did i learn from this
well when i could not find interesting
and comprehensible content that suited
my level
i decided to scale things back instead
of pushing forward with content that
would seriously grow my skills i opted
to learn from easier
shorter resources that were designed
specifically
for learners fortunately my tutor petra
has a website devoted
exclusively to comprehensible and
hungarian content for learners so i had
a lot to choose from there and
by the way if you're learning hungarian
i highly recommend her website called
easy hungarian i
will leave a link in the description box
this did not lead to surprising growth
as my greek routine did but
it did allow me to stay in the game
learning from that easier material for
even a few minutes a day
made sure that i still had some daily
contact with hungarian
and it also made sure that i did not
give up
okay let's move on to my third language
of 2020 which was
danish danish is a kind of the
middle child of the group it's not as
new and exciting as greek
nor do i have as much experience with it
as i do with
hungary in fact i've only been learning
danish for about a year and a half now
before i tell you about my experience
with danish let me give you a sample of
how
the language sounds
exciting and frightening at the same
time isn't it okay now
back to my language learning journey of
the three languages my experiences with
danish were
the most disappointing of last year i
spent the first few months of 2020
learning with asthma danish as part of
my bi-directional translation routine
that i follow for every
new language that i learn that actually
went quite well
once i finished asimo danish i moved on
to a youtube routine similar to the one
that i described earlier for greek
and this went well too i didn't have as
many issues finding good videos with
danish subtitles as i do
with hungarian videos the problem with
danish
came elsewhere while in greek i've got
my tutor daddya and
in hungarian i've got my tutors petra
and anita for danish i did not have a
tutor
i thought i was doing well with just
asimil and the youtube videos but i was
sorely mistaken the truth is one of the
things i find most fascinating and most
motivating as a language learner and
as a person is connecting with people if
i could use a language to chat with
someone look them in the eye
and laugh with them then i'm happy and
if i cannot do this or i'm not at a
level where i can do this just yet
then i tend to struggle it happened to
me once before
with romanian though i apparently did
not learn
my lesson the first time for danish what
i needed in my life were actual
danish people who i could talk to who i
could
connect with i did not have that for
most of the year so i had a difficult
time and i did not make
much progress today i'm happy to say
though that
i have a lovely danish tutor by the name
of a deal that i really enjoy having
conversations with
we meet once a week and our work
together has really helped me start
getting my danish back
on track so what's a lesson learned with
danish
if you're learning a language in order
to do something specific with it then
don't forget to do that thing my main
goal for every language i learn is to
connect
with people so when i forget to actually
get out there and connect with native
speakers
my motivation drops and the language
learning process
becomes more difficult so if you want to
speak
speak if you want to read read maybe not
from the beginning but do it as soon as
you feel ready
it sounds obvious but it's an easy
detail to overlook
okay that covers all three languages i
learned in 2020 but before i go
i want to share one last lesson it's
about learning
three languages at the same time as i
did last year
now this is not something i usually do
nor is it something i usually recommend
but for 2020 since i wanted to learn all
three languages quite badly
i decided to give it a try anyway after
everything i've said
so far i'm sure you have an idea how
it went not very well that's not to say
i did badly i
learned quite a lot of greek and did
eventually get my hungarian back on
track
but danish clearly suffered so at some
points during the year it felt like
less like i was actually learning three
languages i'm more like i was learning
two
or even one and that's certainly not the
result i was hoping for
when last january began will i ever
learn free language at the same time
again
maybe with a bit more planning but
probably not my life revolves around
languages and even then
juggling three languages can be an
incredibly daunting task
for most people i think two is the upper
limit and that's
only if you have lots of extra time
in most cases though i think it's best
to stick to one language for a while
learning well and then move on that's
what i
usually do and what you should probably
do as well
so that's it that's my recap of my
language learning experiences for the
year 2020 and
in part of 2021 if you like this video
you're going to love the video i made
about learning three languages at the
same time and you can watch it by
checking
here happy language learning and as
always
thanks for watching and see you in the
next video
you